ya que la diferencia entre las ratas y
las personas es que cuando una rata no
encuentra la salida en un determinado
extremo del laberinto nunca regresa a
ese lugar es decir algo ahí en nuestras
mentes que nos hace algún modo más
difícil el aprendizaje de lo que puede
resultarle incluso animales menos
inteligentes o que nos hace tal vez más
propensos a repetir los mismos errores a
lo largo de nuestra historia personal y
colectiva los seres humanos tenemos esa
extraña tendencia a tropezar dos y más
veces con la misma piedra
esta historia es la historia de la
repetición de un error
a mediados del siglo 19 gran parte de
las mujeres que daban a luz morían poco
después del parto víctimas de una
enfermedad de causa totalmente
desconocida en ese entonces llamada
fiebre puerperal no se conocía aún la
existencia de las bacterias ni había
ninguna comprensión acerca de las
enfermedades infecciosas hasta que un
médico obstetra que que trabajaba en el
hospital general de viena y que se
llamaba ignacio sem el vice hizo un
descubrimiento notable
la maternidad donde él trabajaba se
componía de dos pabellones pero en uno
que era atendido por médicos y
estudiantes de medicina la cantidad de
mujeres que morían de fiebre puerperal
era mucho mayor a la del otro pabellón
que era atendido por matronas y él tras
mucho observar y pensar se dio cuenta de
que la clave para explicar esta
diferencia debía estar en el hecho de
que los médicos y los estudiantes además
de atender parte hacia las autopsias a
las pacientes que padecían
principalmente de fiebre puerperal cosa
que las matronas no hacían y llegó a la
conclusión de que eran ellos los que
transportaban algún tipo de
contaminación en sus manos desde los
cuerpos de las a las autopsias hasta las
pacientes causándole la enfermedad y
muchas veces la muerte se me el vice
propuso entonces que propuso la norma de
que todos en el pabellón de médicos se
lavarán las manos con agua clorada antes
de examinar a las pacientes y logró de
esa manera reducir drásticamente la
mortalidad
y sus colegas sin embargo fuera por
arrogancia por antipatía personal o por
un apego mal sano a otras teorías sobre
la fiebre puerperal desestimaron sus
observaciones y sus demostraciones
marginaron a ser el vice que terminó
muriendo en la miseria y volvieron a su
práctica habitual de trabajar con las
manos contaminadas práctica que se
mantuvo por muchos años más y que cobró
muchas vidas humanas
la innovación de semmelweis no era fácil
de asimilar hacía referencia a un
problema que no era evidente a simple
vista y obligaba a un cambio que no
solamente era incómodo y tedioso para
los médicos sino que además los obligaba
a admitir que habían estado cometiendo
un descuido
los médicos de hoy estamos expuestos a
otro tipo de contaminación también en
cierto modo invisible y también
peligrosa no me refiero ya a la
contaminación de las manos por gérmenes
sino a una particular forma de
contaminación del juicio clínico de la
evaluación que yo como médico apoyado en
mi experiencia en mi entrenamiento y en
el estudio de la evidencia científica
disponible hago de la situación clínica
a la cual me encuentro enfrentado y de
las posibles formas de abordarla y
manejarla en beneficio del paciente
el agente contaminante al que me estoy
refiriendo es el marketing
principalmente de la industria
farmacéutica pero también de la
industria de los dispositivos médicos en
la industria de alimentos marketing que
busca obviamente que nuestras decisiones
clínicas apunten en la dirección de sus
propios intereses comerciales los que no
necesariamente coinciden y que de hecho
con frecuencia no coinciden con el
interés de los pacientes
la industria farmacéutica gasta en
promoción e incentivos a los médicos el
doble de lo que invierte en
investigación y desarrollo de nuevos
tratamientos los laboratorios no sólo
manipulan y ocultan parte importante de
la evidencia científica para proteger
sus ventas como nos consta sino que
además se encargan de educar a los
médicos a través de múltiples instancias
de formación continua que ellos
auspician y regulan con la ayuda de
líderes de opinión de especialistas
prestigiados a los que ofrecen
atractivos honorarios y mayor prestigio
por dictar ante sus colegas conferencias
promocionales supuestamente educativas
muchas veces con diapositivas y
contenidos entregados por el propio
laboratorio y muy a menudo acompañadas
por una rica escena en un muy buen hotel
o restaurante
estos expertos suelen ser los mismos que
han ido instalando en medicina una
cultura una concepción fármaco céntrica
de la salud física y mental
promoviendo
recomendaciones que apuntan a tratar a
cada vez más pacientes con cada vez más
medicamentos para alteraciones cada vez
más leves de su presión arterial su
crisis en el colesterol de ansiedad ósea
o para variaciones cada vez más
circunstanciales de sus estados de ánimo
de su rendimiento escolar o de la
capacidad para mantenerse quieto y
concentrado la influencia de la
industria no se empuja hacia la sobre
medicalización el sobrediagnóstico el
sobre tratamiento y la asignación
irracional de recursos
además de financiamiento de la educación
del esparcimiento de las degustaciones
culinarias y del turismo de los médicos
los laboratorios gastan enormes sumas de
dinero en una campaña de persuasión
personalizada mediante la visita
sistemática a los médicos por parte de
visitadores médicos cuya misión la cual
llevan a cabo en forma profesional y
efectiva es influir sobre las recetas de
los médicos mediante la entrega de
información sesgada que exagera los
beneficios y omite los riesgos de los
medicamentos junto con obsequios
muestras médicas e invitaciones simpatía
a largos conversación en lo que con
frecuencia suele ir tomando con el
tiempo el aspecto de una relación
amistosa o seudo amistosa
este gigantesco aparato de marketing de
la industria farmacéutica permite
generar altas tasas de prescripción para
sus nuevos productos e incluso para esa
mayoría de nuevos productos introducidos
al mercado con bombos y platillos que a
la luz de la evidencia científica no
constituyen realmente un avance respecto
de medicamentos más antiguos más
económicos y mejor conocidos la
promoción instala en la imagen de un
nuevo medicamento ventajas
muchas veces inexistentes o simplemente
irrelevantes y ojo que los nuevos
medicamentos son justamente aquellos
respecto de cuyos riesgos menos sabemos
y cuando la promoción funciona en
incitando el entusiasmo y adormeciendo
la cautela y el escepticismo necesario y
saludable
el error puede alcanzar proporciones
catastróficas
este medicamento comercializado en eeuu
como firefox y en chile como se os seus
es un antiinflamatorio que gracias a un
potentísimo trabajo de marketing del
entusiasmo colectivo de los médicos se
transformó en un espectacular éxito de
ventas a comienzos de la década del 2000
durante el periodo que logró mantenerse
en el mercado provocó unos 140 mil
ataques cardíacos y accidentes
cerebrovasculares sólo en eeuu matando a
55 mil americanos y dejando con secuelas
a muchos más esto es 14 veces la
cantidad de muertos que provocó el
atentado a las torres gemelas y el
laboratorio fabricante no sólo incentivo
fuertemente su uso de mil maneras sino
que además ocultó los datos que
mostraban su peligrosidad
este es un caso emblemático por la
magnitud de la catástrofe pero hay una
larga lista de casos semejantes
la
tal como tal como los gérmenes en las
manos de los médicos de la maternidad de
viena la presencia infecciosa del
marketing en nuestros propios criterios
de decisión no es evidente a simple
vista al menos no para nosotros mismos
somos ciegos a los efectos inconscientes
subliminales de estrategias de
propaganda y persuasión altamente
sofisticadas y tendemos a creer entonces
que esas estrategias podrán podrán
influir al resto pero no a nosotros
mismos
esto es lo que se conoce como ilusión de
invulnerabilidad
un ejemplo simple todos sabemos los
políticos saben de sobra que la cantidad
de letreros con que un candidato tapiz
es su distrito tiene un impacto directo
sobre su nivel de votación pero cuántos
de ustedes se sienten personalmente
influidos por esos letreros a la hora de
tomar una decisión
en el caso de la profesión médica
sabemos por encuestas
y los médicos creen en general que el
marketing puede influir sobre las
recetas de sus colegas pero no sobre las
propias la evidencia sin embargo muestra
que tanto las creencias de los médicos
sobre los medicamentos como sus
prescripciones muchas veces se ajustan
más a los dictados de la propaganda que
a los datos científicos
evidencia que no viene sino a confirmar
lo obvio porque si la promoción no fuese
eficaz la industria farmacéutica no
seguiría gastando las cantidades
siderales de dinero que gasta en
promoción
ahora ojo que de lo que estamos hablando
es de un fenómeno de sesgo inconsciente
instalado en la mente del médico que es
algo muy distinto de los casos de
corrupción consciente y deliberada que
sabemos que existen pero que son
claramente minoritarios los obsequios de
la industria son efectivos
mayoritariamente no por que corrompan al
médico sino porque lo influyen
inadvertidamente la característica
esencial de estos obsequios que se llama
el dany antropólogo y ex visitador
médico es que son sobornos que no son
considerados sobornos y activan una
norma social implícita pero fundamental
llamada reciprocidad que nos inclina a
ayudar y tender una mano a los que nos
han ayudado y nos han tendido una mano
los datos duros lo que muestran es que
los médicos por ejemplo que tienen un
mayor contacto con visitadores tienen
una tendencia a recetar más medicamentos
medicamentos más nuevos tienen una mayor
disposición a recetar un medicamento que
no está clínicamente indicado por
ejemplo si un paciente lo solicita y
tienden a recetar medicamentos más caros
aun cuando no ofrezcan ventajas sobre
otros más económicos
cuando una persona se expone a la
influencia del marketing digamos una
marca de desodorante o de zapatillas
ella asume finalmente con su decisión
los costos y riesgos que esa influencia
implica cuando un médico se expone a la
influencia del marketing y los
incentivos de industrias interesadas en
sus decisiones clínicas los costos y los
riesgos los asumen sus pacientes sin
ningún poder de decisión y hablamos de
costos y riesgos harto más relevantes
que los implicados en la elección de un
desodorante o par de zapatillas
la medicina científica occidental
constituye uno de los más espectaculares
avances en la historia del hombre y
gracias a ella nos hemos beneficiado de
cambios extraordinarios en nuestra
calidad y cantidad de vida la industria
farmacéutica
pese haber protagonizado los casos más
notables de mala conducta científica y
comercial de la historia reciente ha
hecho aportes fundamentales al avance de
la ciencia médica y debe continuar
haciéndolos no hay alternativas válidas
a los principios del pensamiento
científico para el desarrollo de la
medicina no necesitamos alternativas a
la medicina científica sino una mejor
medicina científica más cauta más
transparente y más independiente la
mayoría de los médicos son personas
honestas responsables y competentes que
se interesan genuinamente por el
bienestar de sus pacientes pero hay un
problema del cual no nos hemos hecho
cargo de manera suficientemente
reflexiva y eficaz y el médico sin marca
como múltiples organizaciones análogas
en el mundo creemos que ya es hora
ahora deben ser la tradición de negación
en el gremio médico y de resignación por
parte de los pacientes
y hora de impulsar un nuevo estándar
ético cultural y legal para una
verdadera antisepsia de alter juicio
clínico
hoy día a ninguno de los presentes se le
ocurriría encender un cigarrillo en este
lugar eso es gracias a un estándar ético
cultural y legal que hace algunos años
no sólo no existía sino que parecía
inimaginable un estándar conquistado por
quienes decidieron no seguir reasignando
se yo los invito a hablar con sus
médicos de este problema a plantearle
sus inquietudes hagan preguntas sin
temor a incomodar incómodo en si es
necesario
pregunten por la evidencia tras la
indicación pregunten por alternativas
más económicas o menos a la moda o no
farmacológicas y preguntan con toda
calma por los conflictos de interés que
todos tenemos el derecho a conocer
confíen en sus médicos pero confían
también en que tanto ellos como ustedes
podemos ser parte de un proceso de
cambio de mentalidad de actitudes y de
conductas porque los cambios que
necesitamos que ocurran esos cambios no
se van a producir solos gracias